well there was Oliver downden talking
about a range of views including a cop
looking at the view from the labor party
now a shadow climate change and Net Zero
secretary Ed miliband joins us now from
Central London
now before we get on to co-op and
climate change I just want your reaction
to the allegations around bullying and
Gavin Williamson we heard there Oliver
Dowden saying that Rishi sunak still has
full confidence in Gavin Williamson that
he was frustrated he shouldn't have sent
those messages but that it was a long
time ago
these are incredibly serious issues
Sophie and I think you know it really
calls into question Rishi sunak's
judgment and the way he made decisions
about his cabinet we already know about
the whole Suella bravaman issue being
reappointed six days after she resigned
I was very noticeable on your show that
Oliver Dowden couldn't deny that Rishi
sunak knew about those issues to do with
potential bullying against Wendy Morton
the chief whip by Gavin Williamson and
yet he reappointed him what it says is
that Rishi sunak was making decisions
simply in his own narrow short-term
interest as far as the conservative
party leadership was concerned not the
national interest and there needs to be
an urgent independent investigation to
exactly what happened we can't have a
cover-up we can't have a whitewash here
what did Rishi zunak know when did he
know it what did Gavin Williamson do and
and and what are the implications of
that
um is this kind of behavior normal I I
said in Parliament is what I'm trying to
get at you know is there a feeling that
you know it's a exceptional place of
work that people get frustrated as Gavin
Williamson's defense appears to be or is
this actually not normal at all will it
let's be honest Sophie Parliament has
got a massive job to do to change our
culture I'm not denying to you that this
might have happened at some point over
the last few decades that this kind of
behavior
um but the point is we've got to change
parliament's got to change and the
example has got to be set from the top
and the point about this is that Rishi
sunak appears to have known that Gavin
Williamson was engaging in this Behavior
you know people in politics are
relatively tough the fact that Wendy
Morton was making a the former Chief
whip was making a complaint about this
suggests how extreme the behavior was
precisely as you say you know there's a
rough and tumble in politics but this
goes well beyond that apparently and it
really is a matter of judgment and the
basis on which Rishi sunak makes
decisions
and I also want to get your reaction to
a story in the Observer saying that they
believe that nurses will be voting for
their first ever National strike action
and some of our viewers were concerned
about the impact that's going to have on
an already stretched NHS do you back the
nurses in the strike action
well look obviously nobody wants to see
a strike go ahead including nurses but
the truth is that this is born of
incredible frustration and dismay on the
part of nurses about what has happened
over 12 years under this government you
know labels in power for 13 years there
never was a nurse's strike what we've
seen is issues of pay issues of
recruitment issues of morale issues as
used showed to Oliver Dowden about what
is happening in the Health Service and
many nurses feel at breaking points so
nobody wants to see this strike go ahead
but as I say it is born of frustration
and distress that so many people feel in
the Health Service about the way it has
been run down over this last decade or
more under the Tories uh now I'm Keen to
talk to you a little bit about cop a big
climate change Summit that we're going
to be seeing in Egypt we're actually see
like I said today he wants to see the UK
made a green energy superpower but of
course we know that the government is uh
they say a prioritizing offshore wind as
Oliver Darden was saying rather than
allowing new onshore wind farms to be
built do you have sympathy with people
who may not want to see onshore wind
near where they live
let me come to that let me start with
the big picture the big picture here
Sophie for the country in the world is
that the UN has told us that the
promises made in Glasgow haven't been
kept we're heading for 2.8 degrees of
global warming and obviously we're also
in the midst of a global energy crisis
now the message that labor would be
taking to [ __ ] 27 and that I will be
taking at the end of this coming week
when I go is that it is now cheaper to
save the world than to destroy it what
do I mean by that I mean that Renewable
Power solar wind and other forms of zero
carbon energy are cheaper than fossil
fuels and this matters so much Sophie
because it means that at home and abroad
we need to be all in on those renewable
and zero carbon Alternatives now that
takes me to onshore wind it is terrible
what Oliver Daphne was saying on your
program earlier he actually made some
important news by saying the government
was committing to carrying on with the
ban on onshore wind that has been in
place the last seven years for your
viewers at home Sophie that is driving
up their bills it's already driven up
but their bills by something like a
hundred pounds it will continue to drive
up their bills by 15 billion pounds
between now and 20 30 of this ban
remains in place so the government is
saying no to the cheapest cleanest form
of power and by the way it's going back
on a promise that Jacob Reese mug made
in the brief period when he was the
business secretary where he said that
they would bring the consenting regime
for onshore wind in line with other
infrastructure it makes no sense and it
makes a complete joke frankly of Rishi
tsuna the man who couldn't even decide
whether he was going to go to cop 27 it
makes a complete joke of the idea that
he's somehow a leader on clean energy
um he also said that
um they will be backing at some new
drilling licenses in the North Sea is an
important transition I guess and to
about energy security we will see what's
happening in Russia just to be very
clear will they oppose new drilling
licenses in the North Sea
well we do oppose them and let me
explain why the truth is and this goes
to the debate we've had about fracking
for example the truth is that wherever
we get our gas from we pay the same
price because the price is set on a
European market so this will make no
difference to bills firstly secondly it
will take years to come on stream this
is not cheap and it's not quick either
and thirdly it drives the coach and
horses through all the commitments we're
making on climate change because if
every country followed our lead we'd end
up with three degrees or more of global
warming precisely the danger that we are
seeking to avoid I agree with alok
Sharma the outgoing cop president on
this he said that he opposes what the
government is doing the answer the way
to cut bills the way to give us energy
security is onshore wind offshore wind
solar and labor has a world leading plan
to say by 2030 all of the all of the
power that the powers are elected system
will come from zero carbon sources
that's what we'd be taking to cop we'd
be saying to people come and be part of
our clean power Alliance so that
actually we can do the right thing on
bills and jobs and security and climate
I want to talk about that uh commitment
because as you say you've committed to
100 of the country's power being
provided by Renewables and nuclear by
2030. now that sounds great but I'm just
questioning whether it's achievable
looking at nuclear for example it takes
five to ten years to build nuclear power
station you've got to get planning
signed off Hinckley Point C was signed
off in 2016 not due to open until 2026.
I mean you've only got eight years to
meet your target two of them you're not
going to be in powerful I mean that's
not realistic is it
it it's stretching and it is absolutely
achievable and you know we had outside
experts issued a whole report on showing
how we would do this and let me explain
how we're going to do it it's going to
come from a combination of Renewable
Power absolutely crucial you know we're
going to double on Shore wind treble
solar quadruple offshore wind and that
is absolutely doable has been confirmed
by outside experts as I say nuclear we
have existing stations and we have
Hinckley coming online you're right that
new nuclear beyond that will be in the
2030s and also crucially something's
going to become more important so if
because some of your viewers will be
asking about so-called intermittency of
Renewable Power like solar and wind
storage will play an increasing role so
yes it's stretching but we've got to do
it we can't afford not to do it you know
it's going to take 93 billion pounds off
bills between now and 2030 this
government and you know I think it shows
a labor party raring to go with the
solutions that this country needs on the
biggest you can face to that I mean we
will be able to create the jobs that we
need
sorry I'm I'm being told by your own
people that I need to speed up so I'm
doing you a favor I promise uh here Mr
Miller oh I want to carry on I want to
go I want you to carry on too well okay
we can then but just to squeeze in one
very final question we know you're
passionate about green energy you drive
an electric car if you've got any guilty
uneco-friendly habits do you take too
many long-haul flights you're partial to
a stake anything you want to get off
your chest
I don't know look I'm not I I think I
would say is I'm certainly not a parent
and a virtue and I don't present myself
uh as that I try and do the right thing
and I think most people try and do the
right thing I just will make this point
though you see our vision quickly has
made this point our vision is of a
country that actually where people have
better lives as a result of the green
transition for example our GB energy our
publicly owned energy generation company
will create jobs and wealth in Britain
Sophie and so my my view on the green
agenda is and this is different from a
decade ago when I was climate change
secretary it's the ethical Choice it's
also the right economic choice the right
choice for quality of life so I think we
can improve people's quality of life as
we go green okay I've got to let you go
thank you very much for being on the
program today Mr miliband